if love is blind then flies would only
had eyes for Aspen she presented herself
like she's the perfect girl on the
planet he met her through an online
Muslim dating site and proposed soon
after leaving Western Sydney to meet s
Marie Morocco
however while Faisal was hoping to
return to wuzzy with a life partner
he now believes s Murr didn't share
their dream she's a greedy person she's
a materialistic the two officially tied
the knot here last year and Faisal was
hardly frugal in making his new bride
feel at home he worked two jobs I have
to appreciate the Muslim women who just
wear the headdress just for the ceremony
then take it off right afterwards that's
a little side note but I'm like I see
you and I appreciate you okay
you would two jobs spending everything
he earned on his wife from Gucci track
suits to live the jackets but right doc
you can't tell a girl girl imma buy you
everything you want then she proceeds on
asking everything she wants you get it
fer and then when things turns back you
can't after that be like Susan
materialistic yeah she needs to take
responsibly first and you take
responsibility from gross all right
right if you have a child they get fat
and it turns out you've been buying them
fatty foods the whole time will you have
responsibility don't wait don't go in
the child
I'm not saying a woman or a child I mean
come on case in this case financially
she was a child yes she didn't have a
job
you made the money she was your
dependant rings necklaces and shoes
holidays Jimmy shoe bro you bought back
and fine dining parties in Morocco and
money wired back to s miss family a
fawning faisal says he was a good
provider no you weren't
you were enabling her demons if I have
someone stay at my place they're crack
addicts now I give them crack I'm a good
provider no [ __ ] you a drug dealer all
right you're dealing in what their
weaknesses don't don't make yourself
table hero it's like it's like a double
standard here where her asking for the
[ __ ] makes her materialistic him giving
her all this [ __ ] makes him a provider
whose transaction he is a transaction
but put it at the same level
she was asking you were given and that's
that no he's wrong for that we agree
should grow bigger and you're gold
giving but faisal says they were
constantly arguing and in April he
walked into an incredible sting when he
came home from a night shifted Woolies
yes it was all prepared for me now all
crime scene the unit had been ransacked
faisal says Asma was waiting for him
with this disturbing message I entered
and she just said to me that you think
you are smart and you are talking to
lawyers about me now see what I do to
you and she just run CCTV catches the
bizarre events that followed Asma runs
from the apartment and into the lift she
presses the button takes a few moments
before the incredible aspera attack she
gives herself to uppercuts to her face
and clutches her cheek she then checks
her handiwork in the mirror seemingly
satisfied with her self-inflicted
punishment estimate eagerly waits for
the lift door to open she takes off down
the hall and into the street to call
police
oblivious to what his wife had cooked up
and concerned for her safety Faisal also
into the police where he was arrested
and charged with assault if convicted he
faced up to 7 years behind bars in a
follow up sucker punch faisal says the
police unwittingly helped s miss steal
his things which she had packed into
these suitcases while he was being held
at the station but more importantly
puzzles freedom was also about to be
taken
did you ever harm as well I really loved
her faisal spend 20 grand on a lawyer
and trawled through hours of CCTV to
find his get out of jail card
and once I saw this I felt relieved that
now the justice boat being served New
South Wales police dropped the assault
charges but never charged his estranged
wife they're making a false accusation
an offence which also carries a jail
term of up to seven years question is
why not the answer is because if they do
they're going to be embarrassed by what
they didn't do at first instance victims
of crime advocate Howard Brown says it
appears police failed to investigate as
mrs. snow claims properly well I haven't
actually heard of a scenario such as
this inflicting injury upon themselves
in order to set up a scenario which
results in someone else being charged if
you haven't heard about this because
you're not looking I know enough he
didn't slap to hurt themselves in order
to make it look like their partner did
it yeah of course this is that power
yell wheel you know I'm saying there's
definitely women out there who are
catalyzing on the fact that domestic
violence is taken so seriously and
they're trying to get their partner's
locked up there trying to get a get out
of relationship free card
I'm just the number of times people just
threaten people just say I'm a call to
police I don't see man calling the
police I'm a wife for man to call the
police on me why she had to do some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] I've seen some
[ __ ] get their tires slashed
their car is broken everything all of
that no cops
but even if we did we're not taking like
if a man broke into a fight the man's
going to jail but it's true it turns out
that you guys can turn a man's life
upside down and if it wasn't for CCTV
this man would be going to jail for a
long time for a crime he never committed
and this is why I always say I don't buy
into the whole believe her
I believe her no I don't know what to
think I need the proof and if the proof
is not there they're not charged this
person but right now we live in a
society where you can claim domestic
abuse you can hurt yourself and then
send somebody else to jail and that to
me is insane
I don't care what it is I don't care
what the crime is hate crime racism
whatever much good inherently believe
you must I know you personally and then
it's a different story it's not I need
to know the facts the fact that I know
you personally I need to have some sort
of we're happy yeah there are certain
people you trust if your wife comes and
tells you something yeah okay
I mean sorry people you're gonna trust
cuz you have that report with them
that's all
and even when these women do get charged
they get one to five years max when he
was gonna fix it if he gets five to ten
and and that's the crazy thing to me
you don't even face the same level of
consequences for the life that you were
trying to take but for all the women who
are making those claims how do you prove
that they intentionally lied you need a
text message you need video proof of
them right if you think rape is hard to
proof a fake rape claim is even harder
to prove that someone intentionally
wanted you to go to jail might the only
reason they know about this person is
cuz they saw her punching her face that
is the only way they know there was no
cameras it was told in jail I just want
to share the story cuz I thought it was
important
you know don't don't enable someone
else's materialism and be careful who
you pick you're surprised that someone
who's materialistic dropped you an ugly
man so she could have other options of
life to me it's not surprising sounds
about right
do I mean closing statements oh no
you're not mad about this stuff it
happens all the time I'm mad about it
not surprised about it I'm just mad
about it yeah are you mad about it oh
well I'm really mad about anything
twice with you yeah that's it for
today's video tell us what you guys
think
[Music]